good afternoon it's my great pleasure to
welcome you to the Witte at Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies here at Yale my name is
Tamar Gendler and I'm the Dean of the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences and I'm
standing before you in the place of in
Shapiro director of the Macmillan Center
who's unable to join you right now
because he's away teaching a seminar but
it is a great honor to replace him
standing before you because it's my
pleasure to welcome an extremely
distinguished lecturer to deliver an
extremely distinguished lecture so our
speaker today I suspect needs very
little introduction to most of you
anne-marie slaughter is the president
and CEO of New America and the Bert
Kerstetter University professor emeritus
of politics and international affairs at
Princeton University
she holds a distinguished record both in
academic and in policy leadership she
was the director of policy planning for
the United States Department of State
the first woman to hold that position
and prior to her government service
professor slaughter served as dean of
Princeton's Woodrow Wilson School of
Public and International Affairs for a
seven-year period from 2002 to 2009 and
prior to that as the J Sinclair
Armstrong professor of international
foreign and comparative law at the
Harvard Law School from 1994 until 2002
she is the author or editor of a wide
range of books both books that address
traditional academic subjects and books
that touch on concerns of life in the
public sphere
so she's author not only of a new world
order and the
that is America keeping faith with our
values in dangerous world but also more
recently of unfinished business women
men work and family an extraordinary
volume which arose out of her 2012
article why women still can't have it
all in the Atlantic which quickly became
one of the most widely read articles in
the history of the magazine and sparked
a renewed debate about the continued
obstacles to genuine equality across
gender lines the talk that we will have
the pleasure of hearing her deliver
today is one of three lectures that
she'll be giving as part of this series
on the strategy of connection they focus
on the topics the chessboard and the web
which is the topic of today's lecture
network strategies for resilience action
and scale which will be the topic of her
lecture tomorrow
and finally on Friday the third in the
series power policy and leadership in a
networked world the lecture series of
which this trio is a part is the Simpson
lectures which are sponsored by the
Macmillan Center and the Yale University
Press
funded by resources from an anonymous
donor in honor of Henry L Stimson member
of the Yale College class of 1889
attorney and statesman whose government
service culminated with his tenure as
Secretary of War during the Second World
War
previous skimps n' lecturers are
individuals of the stature that a
lecture series of this magnitude
deserves previous lectures include
political order in changing societies by
Samuel P Huntington financial crises in
emerging markets by Alexandre Lam who
Lucy arms and influenced by Thomas
Schelling the Arab Center promise of
modernization by ambassador Marwan Lucia
on the democratic maze by John Donne
what happened to national liberation by
Michael Walzer and the imprint of
Congress by our own David Mayhew a
distinguished series indeed with a
distinguished continuation it's my great
pleasure to welcome professor anne-marie
slaughter delighted to be here and I'm
particularly pleased to be giving these
lectures when I was invited to give
these lectures I thought this is the
book that I wanted to write in the
summer of 2012 and in July and June of
2012 the Atlantic article that you've
just heard about came out and my entire
life was turned upside down and pretty
much has been for the last three years
and I've been working in the work on
women and family and men for the last
three years but this project that you're
going to hear that's the summer I plan
to write it and I am now writing it and
I actually conceived of it in 2009 and
2001 I was in government and working for
the next two years in government and
then teaching classes at Princeton on
making networks work so I am deeply
indebted to the Stimson lectures for
finally sort of forcing me to pre-commit
in a way that meant I actually got got
with I'm able to work on this subject
and it is a subject of as I said that
I've been studying and thinking about
for a very long time so I'm going to
today I'm going to give you the first
lecture the chessboard in the web I'm
actually going to start the second
lecture because the time of the might
the length of the subject matter and the
length of the of the time allotted does
not quite track so we will get unless
unless where unless I'm seriously
misjudged the time I am going to be
reading but I will do my very best to
make this as lively as possible I'm
afraid if I don't read given the amount
of content that I have to cover but also
if you
wrong button in my back you'll get a
book talk and it'll sound very different
than this so let's dive in I just want
to make sure I know yep okay here we go
so the creation of the Asian
infrastructure investment bank by China
and 49 other nations in June of this
year was generally regarded as a
diplomatic fiasco for the United States
the US government sought to block the
creation of the bank by urging all of
its allies not to participate it saw the
bank as competition for the Asian
Development Bank which was created by
the United States a cluster of Western
European nations and Taiwan Japan India
and other Asian nations back in 1966
more broadly the AIB the Asian
infrastructure investment bank was seen
as an effort by the Chinese government
to create its own international
financial institutions as an alternative
to the Bretton Woods institutions that
were set up obviously by the West in
will after World War two ironically
President Obama actually fought to
increase China's voting share in the
World Bank and the IMF but was blocked
by Congress and in the wake of that
China pursued this initiative in
addition to a couple of others so the
u.s. pushed all its allies not to join
but actually our Western European allies
were the first to defect Prime Minister
David Cameron announced in March 2015
that Great Britain had important trading
relations with China and that Britain
would thus subscribe as a founding
member of the AIB Germany France and
Italy followed suit as did Australia New
Zealand and South Korea in Asia only
Japan and Canada held back so in in the
traditional terms of geopolitical
competition China won us 0 unfortunately
that's exactly the frame of reference
that led the
US government to adopt the wrong stance
toward the AI I be in the first place
suppose the US had taken a different
perspective from the outset starting
from the proposition that more
investment in infrastructure wherever it
comes from is a positive development for
the people affected and for regional and
ultimately global economic growth the
starting point here is not interstate
competition but rather the level of
well-being for citizens globally the US
should still have been concerned at the
prospect that ARB funds would be might
be invested in ways that would benefit
corrupt governments more than their
citizens something that we've had plenty
of experience with with the World Bank
the u.s. might that's rightly want to
influence the development of the AIB in
terms of the rules and practices it
adopts so if the US goal were maximizing
influence the people of Asia it would
have pursued a very different strategy
influence requires connection the more
dense the web of relationships the
greater the potential influence from
this perspective the US should have done
exactly the opposite of what it did it
should have encouraged its allies and
friends to sign up for the AIB we would
then have had much more insight into the
workings of the bank and much more
ability to influence our friends to
influence its development and indeed
that would have been more effective than
our joining and doing it ourselves which
would have created antibodies so working
through a web of other friends and
allies in the bank that kind of indirect
influence would have been more effective
than if as I said if we joined it
ourselves so these are the two
approaches that I'm going to talk about
the first which is what we did was we
are in competition with China this is
Chuck this is China's way of exerting
influence we will push back against them
and actually what happened that
backfired and we're worse off that's
traditional chessboard geopolitics the
second the approach of thinking about
influence networks of in
fluence how you construct them is the
strategy of the web
the first approach focuses on States the
second on people
the first approach assumes that the
mobile relationship between states is
competition the second that the mobile
relationship is connection
the first approach assumes that power
comes from winning the second that power
flows from the degree of connectedness
and influence are essential for the
conduct of contemporary foreign policy
it in a complex connected and often
still conflictual world but the US
government like most of its peer
government's focuses for more and is far
better equipped for the chessboard world
than for the web world so this has a
long tradition statesmen and foreign
policy experts have long been taught to
view the world as a chess board
analyzing the decisions of powerful
States and anticipating the reactions of
rival States in an endless game of
strategic advantage and indeed the
theoretical basis for interstate
bargaining spelled out by Thomas
Schelling in this strategy of conflict
and by many others since is game theory
not necessarily chess but certainly
poker and so if we think about that this
is the Cuban Missile Crisis this is the
game of chicken right remember we were
eyeball to eye Dean Russ said we were I
ball to eyeball and the other guy just
blinked and no once again we have the
u.s. vs. Russia fortunately a few things
have changed in this picture that
Samantha power our US ambassador to the
United Nations with the Russian
representative but again that's the
chessboard world of geopolitics so as I
said if you think about it it's the
basis with shelling was game theory and
actually the best example of that kind
of chessboard geopolitics now although a
rather gory your version is Game of
Thrones
and again aptly named
Henry Kissinger recently reminded us in
world order the modern chessboard world
is structured by the peace of westphalia
which established the concept of state
sovereignty and the Equality of all
states regardless of the nature of their
domestic arrangements when foreign
policy makers who are operating in the
kissing Jerian or met or Nick Ian's a
tradition think about the international
state system they see states in eternal
competition with other states to advance
their national interests that view of
the world is inherently neither bad nor
good it depends on the nature of a ruler
or government our country's national
interests can be defined as world
domination or as the welfare of its
people or anything in between so again
the chessboard world remains highly
relevant for major domains in foreign
policy and probably in the 1990s in the
early aughts we might not have said that
we thought I think many people thought
we were moving from the chessboard world
to a very different world certainly in
the last five years and certainly in the
last two with the re-emergence of Russia
and not only as a major power but an
aggressive power looking at China
looking at Iran no one would say that
this this is not still highly relevant
but now let's think about what the web
world looks like so before we do let me
say one more thing this is actually a
three level chess set
so Joseph Nye whom I will be referring
to quite a bit and particularly in the
last lecture refers to three level
chests so this is just to show you how
powerful the metaphor is on the top
level is millet the military system in
which the United States is dominant on
the middle level that's the economic
chess game and then Joe actually tries
to say that transnational relations are
the bottom level of a three level chess
game so my I just I don't play a
particularly good of game of chess to
begin with and I certainly can't do it
on three levels at once and I put to you
it is
actually easier to see that bottom level
of chess as a separate and parallel
world of the web and I use this slide to
show you we're not talking about
Charlotte's Web right we're not talking
about one big Center and web around we
are talking about something that really
looks like imagine a visualization of
the Internet where you have a mass of
interconnected networks with a number of
large nodes and countless smaller ones
yeah think about these pictures that
we've seen this is the world at night
seen from a satellite where again you
have very densely densely interconnected
parts of the world all lit up and then
of course you have parts of the world
that have far fewer connections no roads
no lights no and very very you can you
can simply see where the density of
networks is and where where it is not so
this is what the web view of the
International System looks like with
intersecting networks of people of
groups of businesses of institutions of
governments and of criminals criminal
networks a big part of it and so in the
international relations literature and
ok I'll just hold this slide so in the
international relations literature and
also in the halls of the State
Department the participants in the web
world actually let me back up for one
second I just always worry we're on the
slide so let me stay for one more minute
I said intersecting networks of people
and groups and businesses and
institutions in government this is an
example of how licit and illicit trade
networks are interconnected this is
actually this book is now 15 years old
but the point is that the people who are
trafficking in drugs and arms and people
are often the same people who are
trafficking in licit goods or similarly
if to think about climate networks and
increasingly how we are connected by
either wind
those drought conditions but again a way
of thinking about the world and
interconnected zones here networks of
sadly and particularly relevant right
now again thinking about the world in
terms of flows and networks of refugees
and migrants and just more generally if
we think about the web world think of
all the different kinds of networks and
flows people trade energy climate and
digital and you can add your own when we
talk about the web world we talk about
the world of non-state actors at least
that's the classic way that we think
about these actors Clay Shirky the
futurist and actress says this is like
calling the automobile a horseless
carriage right it is telling you what it
is not it is not telling you what these
actors actually are yes we know they're
not States I think it is much more
helpful and productive to think about
the actors and the nodes and the hubs in
networks and to think of these
participants in networks as both they're
both nodes in them and creators of them
States are independent entities that
choose whether or not to ally with other
states to connect or not to connect
that's a government decision members of
a network on the other hand matter only
to the extent that they are durably
connected to other members which brings
the network into being so you have to
that the state of connection is a
pre-wet prerequisite for the web world
so think about Isis and I we're all
thinking about Isis these days but it is
now standard counter-terrorist lore to
say it takes a network to defeat a
network that's fairly evidently because
if you the efforts to destroy single
network nodes so if you take out part of
a network produce a game of whack-a-mole
in which other nodes replace the one
that you took out sometimes in multiples
General Stanley McChrystal known to many
of you it says he teaches here was in
charge of the special operations forces
charged with destroying al-qaeda in Iraq
he analogized the al-qaeda network to
Proteus the Greek god was forever
changing shape and tomorrow we're going
to look at exactly the structure of the
network that he was facing and what he
did to counter it so to see the
international system as a web is to see
a world of networks intersecting
overlapping closely in some places and
more strung out in others as and as that
we we went through it's the world of
global trade of trafficking of climate
change of all the networks of sea air
and land transport I would say if you
think about arms networks terrorist
networks climate change disease the
water wars food insecurity corruption
all of those are network threats and I
would say those are some of the most
pressing 21st century global threats all
right so these are our lenses and it's
actually relatively easy to think about
all global events in with with through
both lenses through both the chessboard
and the web so if you go back first
think about 1949 so most of us who are
trained in foreign policy if you say
1949 we will think at least those of us
who have been educated in the West will
will think 1949 is the date NATO was
created the NATO that we're NATO
alliance the Atlantic Treaty that
created it came into being to counter
what was then the Soviet Union
if you're a web trained expert you're
much more likely to think of 1949 as the
year that the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights was signed standing for the
all human beings and spreading webs of
human dignity in fact Eleanor Roosevelt
course chaired the committee that was
responsible for the Universal
Declaration and in Ken Burns film the
Roosevelt's he captures her telling the
Soviet delegate Wyszynski that the UN
was created for people not for States a
web outlook a couple of frames earlier
in that same series
Jon Meacham is quoted describing her
husband at Yalta in perfect chess terms
Roosevelt he said never made the first
move so this we don't have to just apply
this lens to the 21st century but it's
particularly relevant
more recently in last April and again
very prescient Lee the columnist Jim
Hoagland wrote Washington should now see
to it as if Washington could but
Washington should now see to it that
NATO's Atlantic resolve mission to
bolster Ukraine's neighbors is matched
by Alliance involvement in the
Mediterranean crisis so the Atlantic
resolve is NATO's mission to help to
stand against Russia in Ukraine classic
chessboard mission what Hoagland was
saying is actually these flows of
refugees and this was last April these
are every bit as important and NATO
should focus on them NATO has no idea
how NATO is a chessboard organization so
now let's look at Ukraine itself I want
to talk about a couple actual crises and
how it makes a difference to see to
think about this through these different
perspectives so Russia's annexation of
Crimea and the invasion of eastern
Ukraine looks like a classic chessboard
gambit Ukraine is a country that faces
both East and West and thus finds itself
between two power blocks Russia seeks to
regain its former hegemony over Ukraine
so if you think about it in former
Russian terms obviously Ukraine was a
Soviet Socialist Republic and Russia is
also very unsettled by the prospect of
an adversarial alliance NATO offering
membership to Ukraine and thus
threatening Russian territory directly
so when we analyze this from the
chessboard point of view that's we
either so we see Putin resurgent or we
see depending on our particular point of
view Russia threatened by the expansion
of NATO these are the three potential
NATO members former Republic of
Macedonia u Ukraine and Georgia
so when the Ukrainian people rejected
their government's choice of Russia over
the EU Russia then calculates in the
chessboard perspective that it can
expand its territory and destabilize a
neighboring state at an acceptable cost
other states either friends of the
invaded state or states with a stake in
upholding the status quo or the
international order
way both moves and countermoves trying
to figure out the best strategy from the
web perspective
the story begins and ends with Ukrainian
people and the choices that they are
trying to make and I would say the
choices they have been trying to make
since 2007 this is the second revolution
we have seen in 10 years where the
Ukrainian people rose up against a
deeply corrupt government they've
watched as their neighbors to the west
have begun to flourish and offered
better lives and hope to their children
Ukraine meantime has been mired in
kleptocracy vicious and futile
partisanship and rising inequality and
poverty for the majority of its citizens
as I said they first took to the streets
during the Orange Revolution six years
later they they actually had ended up
back with the very friends dn't they had
first Elstad and their lives had not
improved so from this vantage point from
the web vantage point what potential
membership in the European Union
represents to Ukrainians
is not a geopolitical choosing of sides
it is not weighing in with the West
versus the east it is their best hope of
decent government a majority of
Ukrainians would actually prefer good
relations with both Russia and the EU
for very good economic and geographical
reasons but what they want is an end to
corruption and a functioning democracy
so and that also from the web
perspective is the greatest threat that
Ukraine presents to Vladimir Putin which
is the specter of a successful
revolution against a deeply corrupt
government that is exactly the threat
that Putin faced in Moscow in 2011 when
hundreds of thousands of educated
Muscovites came out to protest the
stealing of the mosque
mayoral mayoral election to complicate
that picture further many of these
protesters looking very similar in these
two slides are themselves digitally
connected they they have lots of
back-and-forth lots of contact and so
for Putin the worst thing that could
happen is that these parallel protesters
would succeed in Ukraine so again both
of these perspectives tell an important
part of a complicated story the world of
states in the world of networks and
flows exist side by side but the Geo
politicians who still run the show in
most Western capitals have spent far
more time on diplomatic and potential
military responses to Russian aggression
than on the economic and social
strategies designed to stabilize and
strengthen the new Ukrainian government
the IMF has negotiated a deal the EU in
the u.s. have sent aid but we don't have
a strategy for helping a very young and
inexperienced set of government
officials spend those funds and govern
in ways that are designed to demonstrate
to their constituents that the
revolution was worth it all right so
that's a way to think about Ukraine from
both these perspectives let's look at
the Middle East all right so Syria when
I first started thinking about this we
would not have looked at Syria
immediately and said that it is the
principle source of the --use threat of
migrants of refugees which again is a
very web threat a chessboard view of
Syria which is the one that the United
States has taken for the last four years
gives you a classic again the US and its
allies lined up essentially against the
government of Syria Iran and Russia on
the other side and in many ways from
that perspective the u.s. view has been
this is not that important to us this is
not going to affect us directly we care
about Israel's security and but as long
as Israel's alright the fact we don't
want to get involved in
Roxi war directly and this from
geopolitically is just not a major
interest from over the last three years
we have watched a political economic and
human humanitarian catastrophe of
immense proportions destroying a country
of 22 million people in one of the most
strategic and historic locations in the
world as I said from the chessboard
perspective the view is not it's just
not our fight we Turkey's a NATO ally as
I said we care about Israel but turkey
until recently even now hasn't been
directly threatened the use of chemical
weapons in defiance of an international
ban briefly rose to the level of a vital
interest that President Obama was
prepared to defend and the rise of the
Islamic state
now increasingly but only in those
instances has Syria risen to the top of
our foreign policy concerns from the web
perspective Syria was a virus that was
always likely to trigger a epidemic of
violence and destabilization spreading
far beyond the region
the characters were Meharry errs were
multiple so mass displacement half of
Syria's homeless half of 22 million
people are homeless either internally
displaced displaced or now externally so
mass displacement civil war economic
contraction religious fanaticism this is
the older picture of Isis carrying out
atrocities environmental degradation
something we don't pay nearly enough
attention to but there was a huge
drought in Syria for much of the arts
driving people into the cities and
making it much harder to actually
support them with rising food prices and
essentially human misery on a on a truly
Titanic scale and memories of torture
brutality and abandonment that will last
for generations playing international
chess has always involved a certain
amount of guesswork about what a state
is planning
but when we think about the world from
the point of view of connected human
beings we can be certain that the
parents whose children are being killed
before their eyes families who lose
their homes and young men who see no
future will respond with grief rage and
ultimately violence spreading chaos and
despair through the web cannot incubate
anything good so the web perspective
also invites a much longer time horizon
over a generation not intervening in
Syria sooner than we probably now are
will prove every bit as dangerous to our
core interests as the immediate threat
of chemical weapons human beings can
nurse trauma and grudges if we certainly
saw in the Balkans and other places for
generations and refugee camps are
notorious breeding grounds for violent
revenge fantasies as the Israelis know
all too well ISIL will have a steady and
regular crop of willing recruits so the
fracturing fracturing of Syria the
consequences for neighboring states and
the rise of extremism was both
foreseeable and foreseen years ago but
our diplomatic military and economic
strategies are designed for the
chessboard not the web if the government
uses chemical weapons we can threaten
force but as a state fractures and sends
millions of desperate people over its
borders to destabilize its neighbors as
opposition forces splinter and fight one
another and as fanaticism threads
spreads through social networks kinship
networks and existing terrorist groups
we are caught without either the mental
frameworks or the portfolio of policies
and tools necessary to respond
effectively Christopher fusel who is a
new America fellow and co-author with
general McChrystal and a 15-year veteran
of Navy SEAL Teams says the vast
majority of our current system for
considering and engaging in conflict is
based on and biased by a nation-state
centric op optic as these systems fall
the vacuum will continue to be filled by
distributed networks with little
recognition of
traditional rules of the game it is our
system not theirs
that will need to adapt so let me come
back now to the chessboard in the web
and talk more theoretically about this
framework of how we're gonna think about
networks and how we actually can develop
specific types of networks as foreign
policy tools to counter some of these
threats as I said in 1961 Thomas
Schelling published the strategy of
conflict where it was just still sort of
the most iconic book in most
international relations classes you
start with it at some point and he he
essentially took game theory and he
looked at relations between the United
States and the Soviet Union and he said
it looks like a zero-sum conflict but it
can be transformed into a positive some
bargaining game or rather set of games
where we can in fact build on some
mutual interests even while we're in
deadly opposition on others he won a
Nobel Prize for economics based in part
on that work and it showed foreign
policy scholars and policy makers
decision makers how to operate in a
world of constant high-stakes
competition the deterrence game of
chicken the coordination game of stag
hunt the cooperation game of prisoner's
dilemma these are strategies that could
be formulated to win them and in any
meeting in the Situation Room in the
White House if you are a scholar
listening to the conversation you can
reduce it to that framework the people
are talking don't use those terms but
those are the terms they are thinking in
Robert Axelrod then followed shelling
with the evolution of cooperation
outlining the basic tit for tat strategy
that transforms a prisoner's dilemma
from a game in which both players are
likely to lose to one in which they
could reach a cooperative outcome
outcome that is second best for each of
them relative to their dominant strategy
but much better than what would actually
happen if they both played chicken and
and collided we need a similar set of
strategies
basic that easy to understand
foundational for of what has been an
enormous literature for a world in which
the modal relationship is connection
rather than competition or conflict so
the country that many would identify and
our peer competitor and note the turns
China has has such a strategy i when my
family and I lived in Shanghai in 2007
to 2008 I vividly remember and it seems
parochial to me to say this now but I
vividly remember the first time I saw
airline routes that were depicted with
China is the hub rather than the United
States so of course the United States is
this peripheral country off here on the
right
China is the center and then you have
Europe off on on the left and as I say
it seems parochial that I wouldn't have
thought about the world that way but we
grow up with maps with the u.s. in the
center that's actually exactly the
representation that China has of itself
when it calls itself the Middle Kingdom
right it's not thinking of itself the
Middle Kingdom as the middle middle of a
hierarchy or the midpoint in a hierarchy
but is the center of a vast web of
tributary relations the center of the
universe in the same way that medieval
Western kingdoms
imagine the earth to be the center of
our galaxy today China sees itself
returning to its historic and rightful
place in the world its grand strategy is
once again to weave a global web of
commercial and political relations which
it describes in terms of a Silk Road
economic belt to the west of China and a
maritime Silk Road to South and
Southeast Asia and when Chinese describe
this strategy it is absolutely a web of
relationships as u.s. Naval Academy
professor Jung Dae young Deng describes
it
China's quote Silk Road strategy is
based upon open networks in Euro Asia
and maritime Asia strung together
through Chinese financed infrastructure
and transportation projects as well as
trade and financial ties
in other words unquote in other words a
world of networks in which all roads
ultimately lead back to Beijing actually
the Obama administration had a similar
strategy and I think it's still there
but it never has articulated the
strategy in web terms in Obama's first
inaugural address he spoke to the
nation's that the United States had
shunned for decades and he said famously
we will extend our hand if you will
unclench your fists seven years later he
has actually convinced Myanmar Cuba and
Iran to do just that I actually think
this is an enormous achievement of this
administration extending our hand means
opening the door to an entire set of
commercial educational cultural and
human relations to weeb weave a web of
interaction and influence the problem is
that while engagement can be a grand
strategy like containment we don't
actually have the tools to
operationalize that in a way that
ensures that the connections we build
serve specific intended purposes in the
strategy of conflict we're able to
identify different situations that
require different sub strategies to
achieve specific outcomes but engagement
as Obama was often critiqued for exactly
this engagement just means to interact
and to connect and so he was ridiculed
for a strategy that sounded like we'll
just go and talk to people we'll just go
and visit as opposed to a strategy of
building specific networks for specific
purposes so the question is who do we
connect how when where and for what
specific purposes and there we have to
turn to network theory just as Schelling
ones turn to bargaining theory different
networks have different properties for
different purposes so recall the great
some of you anyway will recall the great
blackout of the summer of 2003
some of you were very young at that
point in which we had an overloaded
power grid in Ohio that took out the
lights up and down the eastern seaboard
network was not resilient it was
constructed in such a way that taking
out one strand created a cascading
effect how do I go backwards oh okay let
me let me go to go here and see oh man
go backwards so thinking about it and
we're going to come back to this slide
it was the the network was was
essentially constructed in a way if you
took out one sent one piece the whole
thing came apart if it had been
constructed this way if it had been
constructed as a phone tree and a sort
of a decentralized network you'd have
been able to take out the ohio part and
any one one of these pods I'm pointing
here you're looking there okay one of
the of these pods and the whole network
of course would have stayed up I'll turn
ative Li think about the way a virus
spreads through a random but dense
arrangement of contacts that can be
tracked and mapped as a network but only
after the fact in the case of a rapidly
spreading disease we use quarantine and
isolation to disrupt that network when a
meme goes viral we marvel at the power
of the same kinds of decentralized ad
hoc networks to spread information
swiftly and broadly knowing where the
choke points are or the central hubs are
in those networks before death or
delight' spreads across them is critical
to both positive and negative strategies
of dissemination so digital technology
means that we can actually map human
networks in real-time human connections
via voice keyboard and face-to-face
interactions whether virtual or real now
all leave digital signatures so if you
slow down the film of cars on city
streets you think about it you create
those trails of light that will quickly
fill the city creating nodes and edges
and intersections you see where the cars
have gone unless you see the network the
connections between them in theory and
subject to a new generation of privacy
and security regulate
we can track all of human interaction
local to global in the same way mapping
who is connected to whom when and how so
for the rest of this lecture I'm going
to put this project into the context of
broader work on networks in multiple
disciplines and in international
relations and at the same time trying to
show you the ways in which this
particular approach offers a blend of
description of what's actually out there
and prescription that can be
particularly valuable for policymakers
and that can provide a framework for
scholars so let's start with three broad
categories of problems that policymakers
and civic groups and foundations and
global corporations all try to either
solve or to play a part in solving
thinking about sort of these 21st
century web problems I think you can
talk about them as resilience problems
as execution problems and as scale
problems so resilience problems involve
avoiding and responding to crises
whether man-made or natural or both from
a direct military attack to an
earthquake or to a famine execution
problems require the execution of a
specific task or set of tasks by
individual by identifiable individuals
or organizations to accomplish a
concrete affirmative goal whether it's
addressing a financial crisis
implementing a peace treaty or finding
new ways to reduce carbon emissions and
finally scale problems arise in
situations in which challenges are being
met and overcome at the micro level but
not at the macro level so resilience
execution and scale it is possible to
identify specific specific types of
networks resilience networks task
networks and scale networks they can be
tailored to address each of those three
categories of problems and I will break
them into subcategories might so I say
can be tailored to address specific
of problems that the choice of that
phrase reflects my vantage point less as
a scholar than as a policymaker or
expert as somebody or of the member of
the class of people who are responsible
for prescribing and implementing
solutions that dual vantage point is
very familiar to legal scholars as
lawyers of course can change what we
write about by writing about it in a way
that convinces let judges and
legislators to act so we were accustomed
to describing the world analyzing it
writing about it in a way that can
actually address problems and change it
that of course is very different from a
contemporary international relations
perspective from a purely scholarly
perspective that is more interested in
explaining how the world works
so there are scholars like Miles Keller
or Emily Hefner Burton and Alexander
Montgomery who have looked through
Network theory and and written on
network analysis in international
relations reviews the literature shows
you how you can use network analysis to
explain phenomena in the international
world I will draw on their insights on
Friday when we come back to the subject
of power and networks but overall those
are approaches that seek to analyze and
predict the world while these my
perspective is much more an effort to
shape the world that means consuming
literature from multiple different
disciplines and even cherry picking
those approaches that work best to
address these problems over time you
have to put those two together over time
the literature on networks that can
predict and describe the world has to be
tied to the to the literature that
actually tries to prescribe solutions as
we know more about how networks actually
work we'll know more about how to create
them and orchestrate them for specific
purposes ideally we will develop an
entire area of network studies at least
in public policy schools that will bring
together multiple disciplines as we have
in other interdisciplinary areas and
bring scholars and practitioners
together to create a set of studies and
again policy prescriptions so for the
remainder of this lecture let me just
check my time I'm gonna provide an
overview of the approach by talking
about what kinds of networks could
create new policy alternatives for
addressing the problems that we started
out with in Ukraine China and Syria so
we're gonna go back to those three areas
and talk about now what networks and
what kinds of networks could make a
difference so as I said if you're trying
to figure out how to deter Russia from
further destabilize destabilizing
Ukraine that's primarily a chessboard
question it involves the classic
military and diplomatic tools of
deterrence sanctions isolation and
negotiation we have in fact the United
States and the European Union has
succeeded in imposing a high enough
price for Russian aggression to
negotiate a fragile but thus far lasting
deal that is stopped much of the
fighting certainly not all and just this
weekend we had another outbreak so the
and the US France Britain Germany and
Italy announced yesterday that they will
maintain sanctions until Russia fulfills
its part of the mint mint deal and Putin
suggested just this week that he may be
willing to negotiate a restructuring of
a three billion dollar bond that Ukraine
owes Russia that comes due in December
so I would say that the diplomatic track
is slow and unwieldy but the train is
moving on the other hand the longer in
the longer term as I said the biggest
defeat that Ukraine could hand Russia
would be the greatest victory for the
Ukrainian people it would be a
democratic government that delivers the
services that Ukrainians want and need
in a society that provides both
opportunity and prosperity large aid
packages won't do it what we need are a
set of resilience networks that are
designed to strengthen
support people in doing what they
already want to do and these would need
to be distributed networks with lots of
different nodes and links in multiple
directions so that they can withstand
any one node being knocked out just like
the the power crisis and can mobilize
and reach many different people
more specifically Ukraine needs a set of
stabilization and assistance networks
like those that Europe and the United
States put in place in Eastern and
Central Europe after the fall of the
wall one of the principal values of
being a GU candidate member is that the
government officials of the candidate
country at many levels and in all
different policy areas become members of
vast EU policy networks there is a
policy network for everything from
agriculture to telecoms to obviously
finance high security and if you're a
candidate member all your officials and
your judges become parts of those
networks they go to meetings they come
to know their counterparts they absorbed
not only new practices but new standards
of competence and integrity it is
essentially the diplomatic equivalent of
changing a teenager's friends so that
peer pressure works in the direction of
trying to get into a good college rather
than competing to see who can drink the
most or stay up the latest I have great
experience in this latter category and
as we know changing the peer group has
an unbelievably powerful effect and
that's essentially as I said that's the
diplomatic equivalent of just that when
you get government officials and you put
them in the context of highly trained
professional colleagues so those
stabilization and assistance networks a
subcategory of resilience networks are
not limited to governments again if you
take a leaf from the post-soviet
European playbook
you will recall the extraordinary work
that George Soros Open Society
Foundations did teaching fledgling
journalists how to write as part of a
free press and working with government
officials throughout Central and
European Central and Eastern Europe
essentially to treat people how an open
society works the American Bar
Association ran the European and
Eurasian law central European and
Eurasian law initiative Seeley which
trained and assisted tens of thousands
tens of thousands of lawyers judges and
other legal officials in what the rule
of law requires and looks like this
wasn't just about the promotion of US
law Seeley participants could offer
assistance drawn from multiple legal
systems and they were maximally
effective when they worked in a
consultative capacity and responded to
what lawyers and judges from the country
in question needed rather than what we
would have thought they needed building
those networks is hard and often
frustratingly slow work it requires
identifying the right officials ensuring
that they are funded to attend meetings
and to provide assistance on the ground
encouraging and facilitating regular
communication monitoring how the network
is working and troubleshooting disputes
and problems it's a lot of talk
relationship building convening teaching
mentoring and responding but it's the
stuff that successful institutions are
made of it's the best way to make a
government more resilient and
withstanding various shocks that all
governments encounter as well as helping
to improve its performance is to ensure
that individuals who are trying to do
things differently who are stopping
today not taking bribes putting citizens
first cutting through red tape to ensure
that those citizens are inspired
mentored or those officials are inspired
mentored and supported so turn back to
Syria honestly you probably are thinking
that the apocalypse in Syria is so
brutal and so tangled and so immense
that pretty much any policy
prescriptions seem either inadequate or
futile we but you have to try and there
are ways to at least make things better
so we simultaneously on the chess board
side have to work to achieve a political
settlement of this
in civil war that provides for a
transition to some kind of more
pluralist government probably involving
Bashar al-assad for the for the shorter
term and to defeat Isis it's a political
settlement that requires chessboard
thinking and calculations of the best
combinations of carrots and sticks state
to state to get Assad and his backers
Russia and Iran to the negotiating table
and how to create a deal that can
actually stick given the politics within
the Syrian within Syria and across the
region that's exactly what we're trying
to do right now that's what John Kerry
and Sergey Lavrov are trying to do in
terms of brokering a deal and the issue
and pure chessboard thinking is people
like me think that using force in a
limited way or creating safe zones will
force Assad to the table so that's
chessboard thinking it's not we're gonna
win it's how can we actually create
pressure that will get people to the
table and get a our best bargaining
position but if we so there that's
chessboard thinking defeating Isis and I
had no idea just how timely this would
be when we I've started thinking about
this will actually need the same kind of
web approach the general McChrystal and
his co-authors described in his book
team of teams battling al-qaeda in Iraq
they transformed US Special Forces from
a hierarchy into a network a network
will see tomorrow the structure that is
a team of teams they were they
discovered when they started that as a
hierarchy fighting a network they were
completely outpaced that the
decentralization of the al Qaeda Network
and the speed with which autonomous
teams could share knowledge and act left
even our Special Forces operators
flat-footed as they adapted they learned
how to create an action Network a loose
structure that is nevertheless organized
and coordinated enough to accomplish a
specific task that network was based on
the principles of shared consciousness
and empowered execution a distributed
network in which McChrystal and his
immediate staff served as the set
actual node for convening and supporting
but in which every net member of the
network provided and received
information and was empowered to act on
it and as I said tomorrow when we go
through network structures I will show
you a slide of what that looks like new
technological tools that map real-time
communications among people in the way
that public health officials map the
spread of diseases identifying the
central nodes and monitoring emotional
valence can turn an enemy Network into a
continual source of actionable
information so I watched this summer as
someone who essentially studies social
media the way you study epidemiology can
take not only the tweets alkalizes
tweets but can show you who's connected
to whom who's retweeting them and
equally as I said the emotional valence
of those tweets by by various word
analyses what kinds of words are used
how angry they are at where they're
going what kind of responses so you
literally can turn mass communication
into a network that allows you to see
who's where and and what their their
level of activity and emotion is a
longer term option to help the Syrian
people and indeed the entire region is
to radically change the way we think
about refugees and the way we see
refugee refugee camps which is an idea
that Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright is chair of the National
Democratic Institute has promoted
instead of seeing camps as
concentrations of the desperate and the
dispossessed the weak and the vulnerable
who are waiting for a day of return that
may never come we should see them as
hubs of Education Enterprise and equal
rights that can anchor networks of
relatives and friends that extend back
home and around the world individuals
who are seeking refuge from a toxic and
deadly environment could be welcomed
into camps or indeed cities where the
global community represented by
international institutions NGOs and
governments and citizens of other
countries have a chance in fact to
implant ideas of what a very different
look
life could look like to create a self
functioning economy to encourage
entrepreneurship and to educate the
entire population in Liberal
self-government we have 60 million
refugees around the world
60 million that's the size of Belgium
Hungary Israel and a host of Nordic
countries put together and that's the
way to think about it we have entire
countries of refugees who are on on the
move we may not be able to change the
conditions within their homelands but
again we can give them an entirely
different set of tools for when they go
back so you're looking at me and you're
thinking oh right these are the same
refugees that people in France many of
our own governors many of our own
members of Congress are shutting the
door to definitely complicated politics
and always have been but there are other
alternatives so the Egyptian billionaire
Naguib Soros is right now negotiating
with the owners of two Greek islands
with a plan to resettle hundreds of
thousands of refugees and put them to
work building the infrastructure of a
community of a small town of a city on
an island Greek actual Greece actually
has between 600 and 1,500 islands that's
actually the same strategy that China is
pursuing with the people in its
agricultural regions right it's creating
cities and it's bringing people into the
cities and creating economies sources of
Education different ways of living
together you think this is crazy but
Business Insider
ran an article this past summer listing
the 11 cheapest Greek islands for sale
and you can turn to the website private
islands online it seems crazy but why on
earth not why wouldn't you take Islands
that somebody could buy as a resort and
create a safe place where you could in
fact build an infrastructure for
hundreds of thousands of people and
create a hub a positive
of economics of democracy of education
of opportunity if you think about that
we would and you think about that
approach prospectively and that I do
think is a more realistic approach than
Peter teals idea of seasteading but we
could we could combine that to rather
than homesteading you actually have a
world that is far more both prepared for
and resilient to the continuing flows of
millions of people right now those the
camps
wherever refugees are are hubs for
something very different their hubs for
terrorism revenge fantasies armed
insurgency in many parts of the world
they could become hubs of a better life
so now let's go back to China and talk
about the successful launch of the AIA
be and America's unsuccessful attempt to
block it I said at the outset if we take
in the web view of the world we wouldn't
have tried to block it but we did we
could now support the bank and we are
now saying we think this is a very good
idea of making the best of making a
virtue of necessity we can encourage our
allies and build lots of links of
influenced but equally important is to
build a network of diverse government
corporate Civic and individual actors
embodying what the State Department
calls a new model of development in in
the second quadrant development
diplomacy and development review the
State Department says countries require
investments from multiple sources to
achieve sustained and inclusive economic
growth initiatives such as Feed the
Future the u.s. global development lab
and power Africa combined local
ownership private investment innovation
multi-stakeholder partnerships and
mutual accountability so instead of the
old model of development of massive
flows of government aid which is still
the Chinese model of development this is
a far more diverse model that brings
together a whole group of different
actors those networks so if you imagined
applying that model to Southeast Asia
and recognized
the Asia infrastructure investment bank
as one model of development but adopting
our model and creating networks in
across Southeast Asia those would be
replication networks that's my third
category we said resilience networks
action networks and replication networks
that would be structuring links among
existing actors in ways that encourage
the replication of a particular form
model organization or metal or message
so the mechanism of replication can it
can happen if you deliberately
cross-fertilize approaches that are
working from the center or you can build
it into the nodes themselves it's a way
to think about it is if where you have
successful projects and there are many
successful development projects engaged
in by many different actors the problem
is how to scale them but if you create
networks that in fact allow for that
cross fertilization in very efficient
ways and we'll look at some examples
tomorrow it's the equivalent of watching
a meme go viral over social media just
in more and more in slow motion that
model AB replication network does look
more like a hub and spokes Network it
has a very strong Center and it has to
because you have to have connectors and
communicators across fertilizers and
collaboration managers who work to
activate the links among the different
nodes and to create new ones and so
those networks have a different
structure and at a particular kind of
activity at the hub so we might imagine
creating the Asian Development Alliance
with an actual hub in Jakarta or
Singapore and a number of smaller hubs
in other Asian cities all linking as
many corporate government and civic
development projects as possible it's it
could spread examples like power Africa
which is a transaction centred approach
that fosters deals power deals among
host governments the private sector and
donors to create a more bottom-up
approach to providing energy or you
could replicate successful efforts by
many companies to work on strengthening
health and education systems in
communities where they work we could
create so that's an example where we
could create a replication Network as an
alternative to the Chinese development
perspective of ways of thinking about
refugees that are right now we simply
don't have a very effective approaches
or thinking about how you stabilize the
Iranian government never leave sorry
Ukrainian government so I'm gonna move
to questions shortly let me let me let
me just talk about the timeframe here
because the biggest difference or one of
the biggest differences between the
chessboard model and the web model is
the timeframe in a crisis you typically
do need chessboard tools you've got to
act you can't say let's build a network
you have to act quickly and that again
comes back to sanctions the use of force
threats of force diplomatic bluffing but
things that can be done reasonably
quickly strategies of connection the web
strategies of connection tend to be much
longer-term tools if you building these
takes time but the patience and the care
that you put into their creation can pay
off so think about our own successful
long-term strategy of containment the
classic grand strategy in addition to
building alliances of Nations which we
did the American government and many US
civil society groups built support and
resilience networks for movements like
solidarity in Poland the Czech
underground and East German Church
church groups those networks emerged
over years even decades and actively
inserted themselves into national
politics only at key moments but they
were there they were underground
sustaining opposition activists and
expanding their operations over those
decades supporting those networks with
money and material assistance is not
nearly as flashy as imposing sanctions
or threatening force but it is often
much more effective
web strategy is also much more likely to
be positive strategy building and
developing and supporting new
institutions and organisms in places
where they're weak and non-existent
replicating best practices forging a
shared consciousness among teams that
need to act closely together it is a it
is again the way in which I started out
and talking about what Hillary Clinton
calls smart power integrating the tools
of diplomacy and development so if we
think about looking at the world through
these dual lenses as I said chessboard
and the web States and people nations
and networks all at the same time it
means understanding how one world blends
into the other as when the United States
proclaims its desire to stand up for
universal values but then acts on
strictly self-interested power
calculations we think it would think
about how those two worlds have to come
together it means unthinking through the
strategies of both conflict and
connection and having the tools
available to implement them we know how
to assemble a coalition of Nations to
impose sanctions on Iran and a group of
great powers to conduct negotiations to
ensure that Iran is not building a bomb
we don't know how to build commercial
educational and social networks with the
Iranian people networks that would
provide resilience against government
propaganda that would build webs of
collaborative scholarship and research
and jumpstart new enterprises in both
countries yet network building is just
as important to 21st century foreign
policy as nuclear in negotiations
welcome to the web thank you
yes I want to go in and start this
long-term process in such a way that you
it wouldn't be derailed we do have any
sensor where would where would people
look to find some notion of how they
could get started in ways that they
wouldn't be one step forward and two
steps back how could you get enough
traction in those little steps that you
would do in the beginning of a long term
process how would you go about so it's I
mean so when a country is smack in the
middle of crisis I think what I'm
hearing you say it's obviously that's
very difficult to go in and start I mean
if right now in Syria the the things I'm
talking about we would have had to do
some some time ago although we could we
can implement Network strategies around
refugees I think the way you you think
about it is as part of ordinary foreign
policy and on friday i'll talk about
leading in a networked world exercising
power in a networked world and what you
think about is so there are plenty of
fragile states out there and we know
that and we're constantly struggling
with what do you do with fragile states
it's not really development in the
economic sense they're not they're not
ready and so you can think about if if
you have the right sort of mental maps
okay what kind of networks do we need I
just take one example women's networks
very helpful very helpful in conflict
right we know that if you what happens
is the conflicts breaks out women are
excluded we know that when women are at
the peace table we get much better
solutions we often get to a solution
more than we do when it's all male but
then it's too late it's a classic
example of a veer of your story you
can't force a government to bring
women to the be stable what you can do
long-term is create networks of women
and you can create them across ethnic
divides or religious divides you can
empower them to effectively provide
commentary on peace negotiations and
their own proposals as if they were at
the table but not not to do that you you
don't have to you you can do that you
could have done that at say the outset
of the Syrian conflict you could have
said you could see things coming you
could see religious divides there there
were definitely ways to put money into
this and energy into this that's one
example and I think again lots of people
understand the desire to do this in the
State Department and we're developing
ambassadors to youth or ambassadors to
women or ambassadors to civil society
what we don't have is anything more than
let's have a conference let's have some
exchanges and then let's hope we build
relationships and what I want to do is
say no here's the network you have to
build here's the structure of it here's
who has to be in it and here's how we
have to support it and then do it
finally we it has to get as much funding
and attention as the diplomatic
negotiations process yes we would really
have liked to and it's it's a question
that opens up a vast canvas of what of
21st century foreign policy should look
like so I'll just give you one example
and just to frame it so
you know the United States Embassy in
China started tweeting air-quality
wow this was a couple summers ago when
the air quality was terrible and the
Chinese were putting out vastly
underestimated us assessments of the
amount of particles in the air and you
know this is deadly stuff so the u.s.
started sending out accurate tweets and
very quickly the Chinese social media
picked it up and so it went well it went
on to the Chinese networks now that
would be an example of what you would
call people people to diplomacy I might
say you could build environmental
networks to actually monitor air quality
it doesn't have to be through the State
Department well the Chinese of course
thought that was a violation of their
sovereignty and now our response was
what we've got Americans living in China
and we're gonna put this out and we and
you can't stop us from doing this for
our own people but more generally we're
just providing information it gets at
the question of whether engaging people
which Secretary Clinton always she said
you know we're doing
government-to-government diplomacy
government to people diplomacy and
people-to-people diplomacy when we have
relations with China does that mean we
have relations with the Chinese
government or does that mean we have
relations with its people so what I'm
suggesting is both and I'm formalizing
that I'm saying
actually we live in both worlds at the
same time now I just always within a
government's power to isolate its people
right you can be North Korea but if you
don't want to isolate your people and of
course you can monitor their speech you
can you can do everything you want to
make this harder but if you're not gonna
isolate your people then you are living
in the world of the web and in the world
of the web there's a new set of foreign
policy tools and there will be conflicts
and that's what I said you know in some
cases the GAR our government will say
nope you know we're cutting these these
ties but that happens already on you
know sometimes we don't pay attention to
human rights for national security
reasons and sometimes we do and that
upsets our business but I am suggesting
exactly that you simply insist that you
you conduct foreign policy on parallel
tracks
and that that that is necessary to
address the threats that we face yeah we
can't ask to be used from others by
others to further their goals this is
all about furthering our goals I mean I
started from the point of view of a
foreign policy maker I'm all for
furthering our goals and yes absolutely
other governor McGovern's will do the
same right it's not it but the question
is what's furthering our goals to stop
the next global pandemic
what's furthering our goals to counter
China on devine terms of its development
influence what's furthering our goals in
thinking about climate change right my
point is we have all these problems that
we do not have the tools to further our
goals with the chessboard tools just
won't do it and so what happens as this
aggressive we we sort of we hold
conferences and we have exchanges and
we've been we've been having exchanges
forever but there's nothing strategic
about it that's why this is the strategy
of connection there's no strategic
thinking of well if I as as I think of
when I'm when I'm in the chessboard
world if I think well let's see you know
if we could play chicken or we could
cooperate or we could figure you know we
could get a third party and find a way
to coordinate our action the I at least
know what to do when I think about what
category I'm in I don't in this area but
no no we're these are two ways that the
United States will advance its interests
and yes absolutely once once as I said
China does think this way much more than
we do we're just not countering it
because we don't think
this way they I think that in many ways
it's a more of an imperial view and also
China has overseas Chinese throughout
East Asia and is more accustomed as I
said to thinking in those terms and then
you'll have to learn how to counter
their whips or their numbers
so the the chest or the network and the
network paradigm
okay so thank you so that that is just
fascinating that I will go back and look
at the Kissinger book particularly
because in Kissinger's book World Order
which is the ultimate chess book just
board work account he never once
mentions women climate he does mention
terrorism he never mentions energy he
never development so in his mind that
all of this stuff that I think we have
to grapple with and have networks it is
just not there and yet he's describing
that mindset so I will go back and look
at that I'm grateful to you for the that
could add a very interesting dimension
to this so the question of focus this
these two questions are are united
because I'm imagining you set priorities
the way we try to set priorities now
although again Secretary Clinton often
said that when she became Secretary of
State she called former secretaries of
state to ask their advice and they all
said you know pick a couple of things
and focus on theirs and then she would
say so as between al-qaeda advance or
the Pakistani Taliban advancing on
Islamabad the h1n1 epidemic the fallout
from the global financial crisis the
climate change and whatever else was on
the table where am I supposed to pick
and choose in other words which of those
do you want me not to focus on which is
just a reflection of an increasingly
complex set of challenges and I think
anybody in government now will say if
you if you think of various weeks with
with President Obama just when it
couldn't get any worse
Ebola broke out I mean we're sick and so
so I think so that is a problem for the
chessboard world so that's just a
problem that you're now dealing with
chessboard threats and web threats
at the same time how you prioritize them
often you can't often you have to work
on both of them the same time my point
it but but if you can't if you say well
alright we're gonna deal with Syria
first and then Ukraine and then Ebola I
don't think you can depends right or
right now if you think about the climate
conference in Paris or you think about
you know global arms trafficking or
drugs trafficking I my point is that
regardless of the priority you put what
this gives you is a way as a set of
strategic tools so it's not it isn't
changing who's represented and it's not
changing what are the most important
problems those are that's to be decided
by whoever is in charge it is to say
that when the person in charge says what
are we going to do in Ukraine we say
well there's here's the immediate
strategy and here's the longer-term
strategy or we say you know we see a
country that's starting to fall apart
what do we do can we put in networks
that will actually make a difference in
addition to whatever diplomacy we've got
I'm surprised you didn't mention the
drought and serious part of climate
change I meant - sorry it is is actually
in my category of climate change things
do you agree with President Obama that
climate change is most serious foreign
policy or global issue that we have to
face in the future and if so can you
discuss it in terms of the web versus a
chessboard
that's a great question ah yes I do
agree and I agree I mean for the last 10
years actually in 2006
I ran the Princeton project on national
security and we had a lot of people to
come in to rank the greatest challenges
and there were all these former
directors of policy planning and nobody
mentioned pandemics or climate change
and we had a presentation on both and I
came away thinking both were extremely
important and they're not disconnected
again absolutely not but at that point
by 2008 the government department that
was most focused on climate change was
not EPA and it was not energy it was the
Pentagon because when your land is no
good you move right or when you're
underwater when your land dries up you
move and that's the oldest source of
conflict in human history you move and
the people next door do not say come on
down right they they fight so they're
looking at Southeast Asia they're
looking at all these trouble spots
already that are going to get much much
worse so I do agree so this is one where
again the the chessboard perspective
says we need a treaty we need a treaty
right that's what we've been trying to
get meanwhile we're the web perspective
is where Bill Clinton and and Bloomberg
have been now for 10 years with the c40
looking at global cities I would have
thought if you were really thinking in
this perspective from the government's
point of view Yuda said ok fine we'll
negotiate for a treaty but you know
that's gonna take forever let's put
together the greatest source of
emissions globally through cities cities
have a huge and immediate incentive to
get it right in lots of lots of ways for
air pollution reasons and
other reasons and then let's work
together with the Bloomberg's and the
Gates's and the people to create a
global coalition which would be a kind
of network to counter climate change on
the ground and you it wouldn't be
either/or but it would be much more
deliberate now in fact as I said there
is the c40 but the c40 is not nearly as
strong as it would have been if you'd
put government power behind it so that's
just one example of how you could do
that you could then think even more
locally and start thinking at the state
level and you know have a set of have a
set of best practices that cities can
sign up to they're starting to do that
now on the the Convention on
discrimination on the elimination of
discrimination against women right in
other words there ways that cities it's
not binding it's not a treaty but you
can't stop cities from doing it so
that's what I would have done
you